[Music]
in most of the world horse racing is a
fast-paced head spinning event but he
runs a pants northernmost Highland
Hokkaido the races move on yay is a form
of horse racing found only in Hokkaido
in which draft horses pull heavy sleds
down a 200 meter dirt track the sleds
can range from 900 to 2,000 pounds so
Bonnier horses are often twice as big as
their speed encounter policy Kazuki
Kikuchi has been a bond yet jockey for
the past nine years but the history of
this race goes back much further by a
cable Meiji niju link attack on our show
so to state charitable activist
attaching our money knowledge sorry
young lady
this also photo mukashi manga no
covetous stay
go casaya Hatake O'Donnell stated on
your date
sorry not really no do not even stock
the popularity of the races grew and
starting in the 1950s there were four
cities hosting races across Hokkaido
however in recent years interest has
waned and today the races are only held
at this racetrack but that didn't stop
Kikuchi
- content as a diner and we must it ok
thank you sir
pulling one-ton sleds is no easy task
but these draft horses race only every
two weeks and in between they're well
taken care bye-bye
Kaiba normal eating ji-yong so good
tabitha co-insurance yes no my
mono/stereo state no Kiran you miss it a
Roxanna Maggie
Kirika qualitative even Jimmy o'james
aki-nee
Sakura do you go - totosai Kokua arrange
a schedule
Chikara chipping a hockey tequila on
Tony Casillas and for first-time
spectators seeing Bonnie a horses can be
a bit of a shock jock Thomas I saw one
Oxana odor - Jason Tony
it's Kakuma Damon a great guy ok there
have been signs that Bonnie racing may
be regaining popularity either way
kikuchi is happy to be part of this
tradition
why I gave up Mohammed's tinnitus click
I'd a nice moist moment for the harvest
a smaller loop at the end that leaving
behind and down Bernadin Arlene Arlene
operator when indeed the of it doesn't
kill you it diluted Nolan Ross dark area
is the last across the world market a
novice torn apart and easy Eggman
Stephanie honker
and [ __ ] feelin participant in Austrian
carry a virus track part is sniffing ah
- yerevan in the Zita home readin
nauseam
the vision is oval in your not know the
history at apart calm and dull old red
part of it that he worked
Oh me in vitro and a new part of Romani
and unload motive and who betrayed and
zr8 the fest no vdu Testino Alton Bay
mutiny sued upon the moutains ooking or
on the honno-ji said mr. Ezard on fear
of the borscht who've devoted part dot
say no vir cake what Italian ons nuts it
the plane her knowledge is due the safe
travel now the claims history and is a
logical ruin but a neat fellow not the
tradition Stonewall from the ductility
Nev and also a lot of bravest all know
that audit of the south of the DC and
the ordinate of the tweto tea party mrs.
Warner physically
stopped one the old walrus around a
partner meat and done news a in the
rhetoric need in part of hisses and
photo black saying the three AMA
mentioned and operating since we're on
the main zone cause all vvvr Hankuk to
know the it's me Papa Razzi
and echoes are direct for beaten one
deck from a so look
yeah Darmok a lookout II believe me huh
it is there is him for the part is it'll
I went to me mathematische of horrid
beta mentioned on the coast the Houghton
ebay they're all Shiva knows during
early clubs McMahon Savannah on the come
from the wield a speak even Isaiah is a
kind of part of assisted hold predicate
to panic ourself Europe in Venice in
Philip
[Applause]
[Music]
usually rap to me is the backbone of
hip-hop but the music that I make is
different there's no one in my lane
that's doing what I'm doing I'm bar
dealing the king and I make chair I wrap
[Music]
trail ride is basically our culture is
basically what we love to do it's really
a lifestyle if you not hear the
witnesses then you wouldn't understand
back in the days of people before my
grandfather used to saddle up a mule a
donkey backpacking through the woods and
they made a trail well we don't have
woods no more so we ride up and down the
streets two by two in the line
representing the trail riding riding
trucks bringing mother ride horses get
on the party wagon it'd probably be four
hours probably be five our numbers vary
into the thousands we have our own
community we have our own little world
no you got your blues and you got to
zydeco it's a Cajun style of music that
come from Louisiana that's played by a
band or accordion a rubber board lead
guitar some people use keyboards growing
up as a young kid I was always on a
horse trail riding so what I did was I
interpret all that into my music
like I knew he wasn't raised right got a
taste of this country girl homie went
right right when I started rapping that
was really no rap allowed on trail ride
I came in and I wanted to change that
trying to break the bear for young
people to enjoy true right because I was
a youngster out there on the trail ride
but you had a hobby such as trail riding
it'll pull you away from the street I
know because it's a lot of people that
trail ride that used to sell drugs and
used to you know do a lot of stuff that
wasn't right and now they've come to
trail ride and they love my music
[Music]
[Applause]
it means that I make it just for the
culture I represent this for the trail
riders just for the zydeco artists just
for everything that we do country I
really feel like I had something to do
with the changing of the face of chair
[Music]
most people when they think of a jockey
you think of a mouse jockey people who
don't think women can be drivers and
educated obviously we're proving
ourselves I've become the first female
jockey to win the Melbourne Cup it took
150 years for a woman to finally win
[Music]
my name is Michelle Payne and I am a
truckie and horse trainer the horse
racing has been part of our family
before I was born my dad was a jockey
and a horse trainer and my older
brothers and sisters all followed in his
footsteps I was very lucky growing up
with the family where it wasn't ever
suggested that female jockeys couldn't
be as good as the male jockeys and I
think that really helped me the loeben
copies the race that stops the nation
it's such a huge event in Australia as a
jockey it's what we all aim towards from
as young as four or five years old it
was basically my dream to become a
jockey and to win the Melbourne Cup so I
felt very privileged to have them the
first female jockey to win
[Music]
it was a moment of disbelief it was a
moment of years of training and dreaming
of winning our greatest race in
Australia it was an amazing feeling
I think the racing industry is great
because men and women compete equally
and there's no separation between one or
the other in the generation coming
through we've got a lot more female
apprentices and I think that's fantastic
what I'd say it's young children who
would like to be a jockey don't let
people say you can't because obviously
it is possible
that for me has been the most important
part of winning the Melbourne Cup
showing and proving to young girls
coming through and current jockeys that
it is possible
[Music]
[Music]
the marshy region in the South of France
is home to herds of white Camargue
horses one of the oldest and rarest
horse breeds in the world since the
1500s the people of Camargue have upheld
a tradition dedicated to caring for them
Rafi maripaz Reza Nasri Guardian on
Kanaga professor Hawaii event Rita
Quatro Guardian c-17s were familiar me
Pullman car seat on demo was de gallo
uncommon for centuries there has been an
unwavering respect and devotion to the
Camargue horses they appear in artwork
cave paintings and have long been an
inspiration for the people of the region
however in recent years the population
is no longer as strong as it once was
welcome alga se parte de la semana see
surah Papa et nous devons son venture to
Nashua even Samira birthday every day
Murray and other guardians feed groom
and work their horses on the land the
deficit afife Anika said you'll feel set
it to visual Durrani despite all the
Guardians hard work for them it is worth
it the chimeric horses are unequivocally
intertwined with their regional identity
to uphold the tradition that keeps the
buried alive is the genesis of their
passion libyan and Comanche full regalia
so the donkey saw Arab especially uses
for uncle a tradition will continue a
gemstone harvesters ratio Kuti directly
sure Morishima passion
you